today the head of the government of Ukraine and the first
lady of Ukraine represent our state
in the United Kingdom, where the
Coronation of King Charles II and Queen
Kalina took place.
I
congratulate their majesties, true friends of
Ukraine, on this historic event that
begins a new era of the British monarchy.
I wish the royal chan-zon to the third  many
years of successful governance and prosperity to the people of the
United Kingdom and
victories shared with us. It was an
honor to meet personally with his
majesty in London. I remember our
conversation. I remember sincere emotion towards
Ukraine and Ukrainians and Thank you for your support.